- And you see, string theory
is a multiverse theory.
So people say, first of all,
"What is string theory?"
String theory simply says
that all the particles
we see in nature, the
electron, the proton, quarks,
what have you, are nothing but vibrations
on a musical string,
on a tiny, tiny little string.
You know, J. Robert Oppenheimer,
the creator of the atomic bomb,
was so frustrated in the 1950s
with all these subatomic
particles being created
in our atom smashers, that he announced.
He announced one day, that the Nobel Prize
in physics should go to the physicist
who does not discover a
new particle that year.
Well today, we think they're
nothing but musical notes
on these tiny little vibrating strings.
So, what is physics?
Physics is the harmonies you can write
on vibrating strings.
What is chemistry?
Chemistry is the melodies you
can play on these strings.
What is the universe?
The universe is a symphony of strings.
And then, what is the mind of God,
that Albert Einstein so
eloquently wrote about
for the last 30 years of his life?
The mind of God
would be cosmic music,
resonating through
11-dimensional hyperspace.